un globo espía parecía una excentricidad
anacrónica cuando el primero fue
detectado dos semanas atrás hoy en
cambio todo sugiere un Frenesí en los
Cielos 4 ha derribado Estados Unidos en
los últimos días y china denunciaba hoy
que Washington le envió una decena de
globos el año pasado lo ha desvelado el
Ministerio de exteriores Eso sí sin
aportar ninguna prueba ni aclarar Por
qué no la había denunciado hasta ahora
ni Cuál es la naturaleza civil o militar
de esos globos china ha abundado en el
cinismo de Estados Unidos a que ha
calificado como el líder mundial del
espionaje Recuerda que espía tanto a
enemigos como a amigos en una clara
alusión al escándalo que provocó los
pinchazos de los teléfonos de la ex
canciller alemana Ángela Merkel y otros
líderes europeos ha recordado también
que aviones y barcos militares
estadounidenses protagonizaron 657
misiones de reconocimiento en China en
el año pasado habitual que la prensa
aluda estos días a la gran crisis que
provocó el choque aéreo de un avión de
reconocimiento estadounidense 20 años
atrás frente a las costas de Henao con
un caza chino que provocó la muerte del
piloto de este es por todo ello que
china exige a Estados Unidos que primero
se mire a sí misma que cambie su actitud
y que deje de difamar y de fomentar la
confrontación entre países